could Chris Harrison be the next
Bachelor
hey i'm danny director with ET now we
ask the host after the men tell all I
would I would I believe in the show the
only problem is I wouldn't be good on
the show now what because I'm the host
of the show and I produce on the show I
know exactly what we're producing right
now which it would be hard and you
really have to I know it sounds silly
but you have to have a little bit of
innocence and naivete about just walking
in and really let it go and I wouldn't I
would be thinking about is this a good
scene right where's it gonna fit in the
show and is are we getting what we need
as the bachelor and bachelorette you get
to go on some incredible dates but is
there one that Bachelorette and II
didn't get to go on I wish we would have
done like a South African safari that's
always been a dream of mine definitely
on my bucket list
I don't know how feasible that would be
you know I'm sure some of the guys would
have jumped off into the wild there's
something crazy but yeah South African
safari would have been nice so that's
gonna work out but does she have any
regrets obviously one of the bigger
regrets is the conversation with Erica
do you feel like you've been comfortable
in and that's all the whole time
in my comfortable and natural by the
time not a chance
but do I work my ass off and stay up
late so that everyone knows that I am
here for them yeah I do you have no idea
what it takes no idea how exhausted I am
you have no clue how it is look at
people in the face and send them home
you've no idea and so for you to sit
here and tell me that I'm a poker face
it's so offensive
it's the final moments and he shared
with contestant Eric Hill who passed
away shortly after leaving this season
that's been played out I think it's you
know obviously that's a huge regret of
mine while her last conversation with
Eric stood out she said she was proud of
how the show handled his passing I know
people have their opinions on how the
Eric situation was handled you know as
far as how we handled you know the death
of Eric that was another real part of
the show and I think so many times
people say like oh this is not reality
like this is reality and I think we
showed that and it's hard to watch and
it was hard to be in that moment but I
think it was real and we wanted to share
Eric with the world we really did you
can find out who Andy chooses when the
finale airs July 28th for ET now i'm
danny director